von Münstermann Frau Müller und sagte
gerade Öl ins Feuer
wie ist das der Grund warum Politik hier
auch so zögerlich ist an dem Punkt man
hat das Gefühl keiner führt so richtig
von vorne gab heute glaube ich eine eine
Titelseite der Hamburger Morgenpost
Kollegen hier in Hamburg ist vor der
Olaf Scholz drauf oben drüber steht
vermisst
ja dass das gefällt Herrn märz und es
war ja originell
wir suchen naja es gibt ja noch eine
geschäftsführende Kanzlerin die im Amt
ist die CDU ist eigentlich auch noch mal
die Bühne nutzen könnte auch wenn sie
nur noch anderthalb Wochen vielleicht im
Amt ist aber sagen könnte liebe Leute es
tut uns leid wir haben viel zu lange die
einen in Sicherheit gewogen es gibt
keine Impfpflicht jetzt wieder alle dran
aber wir haben in Sachsen bald die
Triage Intensivpatienten werden durch
Deutschland gecarrt man weiß dass
mittlerweile aus dem Umfeld glaube ich
in München mit Baby schwer krank es gibt
keine Klinik mehr die eine aufnimmt das
kommt bei den Menschen an und auch bei
denen die sich haben impfen lassen und
die alles richtig gemacht haben und
diese diese Mittel zwischen die eine
nicht verbrellen die anderen dann
mitnehmen wollen das hat man lange
probiert ich glaube jetzt ist eine Zeit
vom Winter vor Weihnachten wo man
eigentlich sagen müsste wir machen auch
noch mal ein Lockdown oder eine Art
Lockdown aber die eine will nicht mehr
reden der andere kann noch nicht reden
oder traut sich nicht vor der Vorlage
also sehr schwierig und ich fand die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz letzte
Woche da wurde zwar einiges beschlossen
aber so richtig in den Mund nehmen dass
die Situation
so ist dass man die Bevölkerung jetzt
wieder auf irgendwas einschwören muss
wollte dann doch keiner so das ist das
ein und das andere ist diese
katastrophale Kommunikation sie sagen es
ist absurd das am
Bundesgesundheitsminister als Erster das
Ende der epidemischen Lage verkündet
übrigens flankiert von Friedrich Merz
der das gut war langsam also bitte bei
den Fakten bleiben es hat keiner
verkündet sondern wir haben das beide im
Herbst für möglich angesehen wir haben
uns beide korrigiert in der letzten
Woche und wir haben eine
wir haben die Lage so eingeschätzt dass
es möglich wäre wir haben gesehen dass
die Zahlen Jens Spahn hat gesagt aus
meiner Sicht kann die epidemische Lage
beendet sie zitieren ihn jetzt aus dem
aus dem August heute journal aus dem
heute haben in der letzten Woche eine
positive aus dem Oktober ja da wurden 24
September
unterstützt ich habe so ungefähr zum
selben Zeitpunkt gesagt dass diese
Epidemie was war denn das Problem
worüber haben wir denn diskutiert wir
ist eine Möglichkeit
zurückgeben in die Parlamente
Entscheidungen zu treffen und nicht mehr
auf dem Verordnungswege
Grundrechtseinschränkungen zu
ermöglichen so wir haben in der letzten
Woche eine bundestagsdiskussion gehabt
und von Münstermann wir haben ja auch
etwas erlebt was auch einigermaßen
außergewöhnlich ist wir haben noch keine
Regierung aber die Parlamentsmehrheit
die die zukünftige Regierung stellen
soll hat das Verfahren an sich gezogen
und hat gesagt wir machen das jetzt
selbst so und darüber hat Streit gegeben
im Bundestag doch genauso warten wir
dabei gewesen wir haben in der letzten
Woche erlebt dass diese Koalition
offensichtlich getrieben von der FDP
einen kompletten Systemwechsel in den
Rechtsgrundlagen wollte den haben sie
durchgesetzt den fanden sie doch auch in
Ordnung darf ich noch mal sagen wir
haben jetzt dagegen gestimmt sie haben
gegen ihre eigene Aussage aus dem
Oktober bestimmt also Jens Spahn und ich
und einige andere haben gesagt wir
können jetzt in dieser prekären Lage das
nicht tun was wir im Oktober erhofft
haben dass wir nämlich diesen
Systemwechsel machen können nichts
anderes sage ich doch ja mir geht es nur
um dieses um diese wirklich chaotische
Kommunikation einerseits und das andere
ist nicht führen wirklich von vorne
meine wer soll denn da noch durchblicken
das gleiche Desaster haben wir jetzt
wieder bei der booster-impfung meine wie
ist denn sowas zu erklären dass ein
Bundesgesundheitsminister sagt also
wir hören einfach mal rein sich
innerhalb kürzester Zeit selber
korrigieren muss geht um die Frage
biontech oder moderner und seine Aussage
ein weiteres Mal kassiert und sagt da
bin ich wahrscheinlich missverstanden
worden das ist das Mindeste was man
sagen kann bitteschön
ist der Eindruck entstanden wir würden
nur deshalb stärker auf den Impfstoff
von Modern ersetzen um einen möglichen
Verfall dieser Impfstoffe im ersten
Quartal 22 zu vermeiden das ist zwar ein
wichtiger Aspekt das würde ich
ausdrücklich sagen natürlich auch ein
Aspekt aber es ist nicht der
entscheidende entscheidend ist dass sich
unser biontech-lager so schnell lehrt
dass wir ab der nächsten Woche
vorübergehend nicht mehr als zwei bis
drei Millionen Dosen ist
biontech-impfstoffs pro Woche
zur Verfügung stellen können für die
Versorgung
war da sehr zerknirscht hat das auch
noch mal erklärt hat sich auch
entschuldigt der oton endet ein bisschen
eher aber trotzdem was löst das aus bei
den Leuten also erst kriegst du die
Nachricht was auf der Gouda den du da im
Kühlschrank hast der läuft jetzt ab
deswegen lass uns den bitte zuerst essen
dann korrigiert man sich wieder und sagt
nee sowas gar nicht gemeint weil
eigentlich haben wir gar nichts mehr vom
Emmentaler das ist eigentlich das
Hauptproblem und dann kommt die STIKO
und sagte ja moderner alles Gute und
schön aber unter 30 empfehlen wir
überhaupt keine moderner Impfung das
heißt da kannst du an dem Punkt auch mit
Booster nicht mehr weitermachen was
sollst du denn als Arzt und als Patient
dann noch glaubt Herr März lacht schon
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt nur in der
Tat dass das war ein bisschen
unglücklich so also ums vorsichtig
auszudrücken und letztendlich ist es ja
so dass man auch noch mal darauf
hinweisen muss dass beide im Stoffe also
biontech und moderner ja sehr gute
Impfstoffe sind das zeigen auch die
Daten wie lange sie wirken mit ihrem
Impfschutz wie lange das anhält und es
ist eben möglich für die älteren auf
jeden Fall auch mit Moder dann die diese
boosterimpfung zu bekommen es ist beißt
sich auch überhaupt nicht mit anderen
Impfstoffen die vorher gemacht worden
sind wahrscheinlich wird es auch so sein
wir die Studien schon gezeigt haben für
diese kreuzimpfungen also wenn man zwei
verschiedene bei erster und zweiter
bekommen hat dass das dann sogar besser
ist also von daher ist das hat ja keiner
gesagt ja und es verstehen sie genau
deswegen das war ja nicht die
Kommunikation genau also da würde ich
mal auch mit dem Aussagen also die
Kommunikation das hätte man vielleicht
stringenter und besser machen können
lässt gerade auch jetzt in dieser
Situation wo wir die Menschen ja wieder
dazu bewegen wollen sich noch mal
Boostern zu lassen gerade auch die die
nur einmal geimpft worden sind nämlich
mit dem Johnson & Johnson Impfstoff das
ist ja auch noch ganz wichtig denn bei
den Menschen ist zu erwarten oder zu
befürchten dass dass das da schon sehr
viel schneller nachgelassen hat in der
Schutzwirkung kommen sondern ich bin
keine Ärztin aber wir haben am
Wochenende denn das kam ja schön
Freitagnachmittag das ist ja sowieso
unklug für politische Kommunikation ein
Brief zu schreiben der dann über das
Wochenende breit getreten wird in keiner
richtig gelesen hat aber alle sprechen
drüber die Hausärzte wo wir angerufen
haben waren die waren outrage sagt man
im englischen die waren so sauer und so
fassungslos und die Verknüpfung das
hätte man sich einfach sparen müssen von
wir haben nicht mehr so viel auf Lager
was stimmt also das ist eine Tatsache
mit dem Auslaufen des moderner
Impfstoffs im Frühjahr das ist nicht nur
unglücklich dass es schlicht schlecht
gemacht und
sie als politischer Vollprofi wie kann
sowas passieren solche Fehler passieren
jedem von uns ist immer zu Pandemie naja
also es hat gestern Abend in der ARD
eine interessante Sendung in den
Tagesthemen dazu gegeben und einen
interessanten Kommentar eines Kollegen
von ihnen der gesagt hat wer fragt
eigentlich nach wenn er gegen Tetanus
geimpft wird oder gegen eine normale
Grippe geimpft wird wer der Hersteller
ist wir haben uns doch mittlerweile auf
diese Diskussion von diesen Herstellern
in einer Art und Weise
kapriziert die doch mittlerweile
einigermaßen irrational ist doch da also
wenn man das doch weiß aus dem Jahr das
ist ich zitiere ja nur mal Kollegen von
Herrn Lanz nein
Aspekt da haben sie völlig recht also
wenn man sagt was ich alles korrigieren
Sie mich wenn ich quatsch erzähle also
wenn wir uns gegen Hepatitis oder auch
Tetanus oder was auch immer impfen
lassen die klinischen Studien zu diesen
Impfungen waren glaube ich deutlich
weniger ausführlich als die Studien die
wir zu corona-impfungen gemacht haben
eine super Studienlage und wir verfolgen
es ja auch paar also
messenger RNA richtig ja richtig und das
da ist viel Irrationalität im Spiel der
hat Herr März natürlich Recht und der
Kollege der das so kommentiert hat auch
recht aber die andere ist politische
Kommunikation aber deswegen würde ich
mal uns allen raten mal auch in den
Emotionen da ein bisschen runterzukommen
und mal darüber das Ziel zu sprechen
dass wir gemeinsam haben sollten was wir
aber offensichtlich in dieser
Gesellschaft nicht uneingeschränkt haben
dass wir nämlich unverändert an dem Ziel
festhalten so schnell wie möglich und so
viel wie möglich zu impfen so und das
ist doch der eigentliche Punkt über den
wir heute sprechen müssen wie schaffen
wir das so
Irritation entstanden sind in der
letzten Woche ist unbestritten ich habe
das von meinem Hausarzt auch gehört der
sich darüber zurecht auch erregt hat
aber jetzt müssen wir doch mal sehen
dass wir das so schnell wie möglich in
den Griff bekommen und wir haben hier
angefangen über die Frage zu diskutieren
Impfpflicht ja oder nein wenn meine
Punkte gemacht dazu und sagt nochmal
jetzt bitte so schnell wie möglich so
viel wie möglich und auch jetzt wirklich
konsequent gegen diese corona-leugner
und Impfgegner mal etwas unternehmen es
ist jetzt gut mit Toleranz und allem
Rücksicht nehmen was wir da in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten niemals
gemacht haben es ist jetzt schluss mit
Toleranz aber was folgt denn für sie
daraus wenn ich sie frage sind sie dann
bereiten eine Impfpflicht anzusagen
sagen sagen sie nein er muss sich drüber
nachdenken doch das ist so richtig
schwierig schließlich nicht aus aber ich
schließe es auch nicht wirklich jetzt
also das Verfassungsgericht oder nicht
das ist nicht mein Thema der
entscheidende Punkt ist doch wir setzen
wir das denn jetzt heute durch und gibt
es vielleicht Möglichkeiten deswegen
habe ich doch hier gerade auch ganz zu
Beginn der Sendung den Vorschlag gemacht
ganz konsequent zu gehen und nicht mehr
zu akzeptieren dass es davon
irgendwelche Ausnahmen keine Impfpflicht
sie wollen sie scheuen sich davon eine
Impfpflicht die wahrscheinlich viel
schneller auch durchgesetzt werden kann
als ein Gesetz dass uns zur Impfung
verpflichtet so und dann ist doch genau
so wie er gerade gesagt hat wie geht das
denn dann dann klingelt bei mir jemand
und stellt die Frage Polizei Ordnungsamt
Staatsanwaltschaft fragt nach Herr märz
sind sie schon geimpft ja oder nein und
dann sage ich das geht hier nichts an
was geht denn wie geht das denn also
nein ich bin dafür dass wir es faktisch
durchsetzen dass diese Impfpflicht
gemacht wird und erinnern sich mal als
letzte Jahr da haben wir gesagt klar
noch mal klare politische Kommunikation
sie sind dafür dass wir es faktisch
durchsetzen wir sind aber Impfpflicht
ich bin dafür dass wir eine Impfpflicht
Tisch durchsetzen so und faktisch
durchsetzen heißt 2G ganz konsequent 2G
das ist aber keine Impfpflicht das ist
die impfpflichtung das ist ein weiterer
Versuch das böse Wort Impfpflicht
sozusagen großräumig zu umfahren und
wollen aber gleichzeitig auf eine
Impfpflicht hinaus ist 2G für sie eine
Impfpflicht ja also es kommt darauf an
wo flächendeckend das überall umgesetzt
wird aber ob man dann wirklich auch die
ganzen Menschen erreicht die jetzt also
stringent gegen eine Impfung sind also
sich also von vornherein verwehren auch
gegenüber jeglicher rationalen
Begründung und Herleitungen dass das
steht auch dahin also vielleicht könnte
man eine Brücke bauen also viele
Menschen vielleicht auch zum Beispiel
Frau Wagenknecht würden sich ja schon
impfen lassen wenn sie eine Alternative
hätten zu denen angeblich noch nicht gut
untersuchten jetzt gerade vier
zugelassenen Impfstoffen gegen das
Coronavirus nämlich mit einem Tod
Impfstoff und dieser von der Firma
novawachs der wird ja jetzt demnächst
zugelassen werden das heißt da könnte
man dann sagen guck mal hier also
andere jetzt eine Alternative nach
konventioneller mit alles gut würde
gehen ich weiß verstehe ich alles Frau
milbon dauert aber auch alles wir sind
doch jetzt in der Situation wir müssen
noch jetzt an jetzt
alle heute impfen lassen dann dauert das
mehr als vier Wochen bis die alle
geschützt sind also das bringt uns aus
dieser Lage nicht raus und Herr Merz
wenn sie sagen konsequent 2G ich sehe
den Unterschied nicht zur Impfpflicht
die diskutiert wird weil in keinen Land
Europas auch nicht in Österreich wo
jetzt eine ausgerufen wurde niemand
denkt daran Menschen aus ihren Häusern
zu zern und ihnen eine Nadel in den in
den Arm zu rammen das geht ja nicht also
dass das geht in keinem Land Europas
sondern es geht darum darfst du dorthin
wo andere Menschen auch sind umgeimpft
das ist das was sie mit konsequent 2G
meinen das ist aber das was eigentlich
Impfpflicht bedeutet Impfpflicht
bedeutet dass man dort nicht hin kann es
ist sogar nicht die Frage ob man das am
Arbeitsplatz überhaupt vorschreiben kann
und Menschen in Lebensunterhalt nehmen
es ist die Frage was tut man mit
Menschen die unkündbar sind zum Beispiel
Beamtinnen Beamte wenn die dann sagen
ich mache das nicht was macht man dann
mit denen
das sind die Fragen die sich jetzt
stellen aber dieses
schreckenden Menschen Zwangs zu impfen
mit der Nadel in den Arm und
körperlicher Gewalt das wird nirgendwo
diskutiert das funktioniert nicht in
Europa
diskutiert mit Impfpflicht durch die
Hintertür ja und das haben alle
abgelehnt ich bin uns mal hier auf dem
der Blick zurück ich weiß Dinge sie
haben doch selber gerade für sich in
Anspruch genommen sich korrigieren zu
können ja so und an dem Punkt müssen wir
uns doch auch korrigieren meine 2G Frau
Milbe und sagte gefunden was ganz
interessantes 2G hatten wir hatten nicht
funktioniert
es war nur eine Woche zwei genauso
eine Idee aber wie hat das funktioniert
sehr sehr schwer zu kontrollieren ist
die Erfahrung also die Polizei hat in
dieser Woche 170.000 mal kontrolliert ob
die Leute ihren Impfpass oder ihren
genesenen Status mithaben
das ist eine große Zusatzbelastung und
trotzdem erwischt man nur sehr wenig
davon und wenn alle auf der Straße
unterwegs sind dann ist es schwierig in
jedem Geschäft zu kontrollieren in jedem
Restaurant zu kontrollieren überall in
der Öffentlichkeit zu kontrollieren sehr
sehr schwer deswegen jetzt der Lockdown
für alle weil es einfach eine Bremse
braucht jetzt bei der Impfpflicht der
diskutiert das
verhaltensverwaltungsstrafen verhängt
werden dass die Rede von ungefähr 3000
Euro 3600 Euro was richtig weh tut das
führt dann natürlich auch zu Haftstrafen
wenn es jemand nicht zahlt also das ist
schon empfindlich wahrscheinlich auch
mehrfach weil sonst könnte man sich ja
einmal frei kaufen und das dass man
sieht jetzt schon dass das eine
Auswirkung hat also es gehen Leute
impfen es war noch nie so viele
erststiche wie der letzten Woche das
sieht sehr gut aus haben sie das in
Österreich nicht eingeführt ist jetzt in
Österreich eine Impfpflicht gesetzlich
eingeführt
bis dort
im Februar oder das ausgestaltet aber so
richtig weiß es niemand dass er diese
Fragen sind ich habe ein bisschen den
Eindruck die Politik wünscht sich das
bis dahin eine Impfquote erreicht wird
wo sie nicht mehr notwendig sein wird
und dass ihnen erspart das wirklich
durchzusetzen weil so einfach ist es
nicht ein Teil lässt sich durchaus die
die bisher faul waren die sich gedacht
haben ich warte auf einen anderen
Impfstoff und so die gehen jetzt mal
impfen ohne ihr Gesicht zu verlieren es
gibt aber einen Teil der totale
Impfgegner sind die werden das nutzen um
ihre Agenda zu treiben und das nicht zu
zahlen ins Gefängnis zu gehen und so
weiter
es gibt noch einen Teil der haben
einfach Angst und viele offene Fragen
und die muss man wenn man schon eine
Impfpflicht macht parallel erreichen und
Ihre Fragen beantworten ja das geschieht
zu wenig sowohl in Österreich als auch
in Deutschland wenn ich das beobachte
wir haben seine Sendung gemacht mit zu
sehr Fragen zur Impfung und Ärzte
Antworten und Ärztinnen und das war
unglaublich wie viele Fragen offen sind
die Leute bekommen keine Antworten
darauf und dann nützt eine Pflicht dann
auch nichts also da braucht seine ganz
andere Methode der Impfkampagne der
Kommunikation damit man an die drankommt
die unsicher sind aber noch erreichbar
wir kommen soll man sie wollten gerade
ja hier ist schon irre was wir für
trostszenarien also ich finde das ganz
schön dass man sagt wir setzen das im
Februar an wir hoffen aber dass wir es
vorher irgendwie schaffen in der
Vermutung hatten wir oder ich bin
überzeugt dass das genauso ist in
Deutschland haben wir bis vor kurzem die
Diskussion ob Arbeitgeber überhaupt
fragen dürfen ob die die in ihren also
in ihrem Büro kommen geimpft sind oder
genesen sind oder sich die mussten sich
auch nicht testen lassen also wir sagen
der der Sprung in der Diskussion ist
schon sehr sehr enormen aber das sind
wir schon weit drüber zum Beispiel also
bei uns gilt schon länger 3G am
Arbeitsplatz und in Wien das heißt der
Arbeitgeber ist verpflichtet dass du
kontrollieren und auch zu kontrollieren
ob die die nicht geimpft sind dass sie
jeden Tag einen Test mit haben also gute
Möglichkeiten gewesen auch im Angebot
und zum Schluss Entschuldigung also ich
wollte nur ganz kurz noch sagen und die
Frage nach den Aussichten für die
nächsten Wochen weihnachten steht vor
der Tür das ist wieder dieses
grauenvolle Dejavue wir stehen da wieder
Weihnachten fällt möglicherweise ins
Wasser die Frage der alten Leute in
Pflegeheim in Altenheim also eben das
Thema glaube ich privat ja auch dass das
also das zerreißt dann doch das Herz
wenn man das sieht allerdings also die
Sache ist ja die mit der Impfpflicht
wenn wir sie jetzt diskutieren waren wir
sie einführen 1 Februar in Österreich
das kommt eben für die jetzige vierte
Welle einfach zu spät damit kriegen wir
das nicht mit der mit der Kurve
sozusagen runter sondern wir müssen
jetzt eben kontaktbeschränkungen machen
also vernünftigerweise auch wenn das
noch nicht von der Politik eingeführt
worden ist jeder für sich dass wir das
wirklich genau überprüft was muss sein
und wo kann möglicherweise darauf
verzichten dass das eine und bei der bei
der Impfpflicht da würde man sich dann
fragen jetzt sind die Stimmen alle laut
die sagen ja wir brauchen unbedingt eine
Impfpflicht weil jetzt ja der Druck auch
da ist mit der vierten Welle aber was
machen wir wenn der Zustand eingetreten
sein wird den der Herr Spanier schon
angekündigt hat entweder geimpft genesen
oder gestorben das heißt wenn die Welle
wieder runtergeht Richtung Frühling der
Druck nicht mehr da ist wie das dann mit
der Impfpflicht und ihrer
durchsetzungsmöglichkeit ist in der
Gesellschaft denn das ist ja dann so
dann hat man tatsächlich den Eindruck
und der ist auch begründet dass die
Sache jetzt langsam zu Ende geht dass
wir aus der Pandemie rauskommen und dann
eben auch in einen einigermaßen stabilen
Zustand drüber gehen weil wir eine
grundimmunität in der Bevölkerung haben
werden dann ist die Frage der
Impfpflicht dann noch mal ganz neu zu
bewerten natürlich wollen wir dass das
nicht wiederkommt und dass wir eben
diese grundimmunität auch behalten wir
müssen dann eben abwarten wie das mit
der Booster Impfung funktioniert eine
theoretische Frage noch zum Schluss ich
frage mich manchmal warum wenn ich ein
bisschen pragmatischer sind in diesem
Land das verstehe ich nicht warum muss
man nicht einfach sagen es geht doch um
die älteren um die sogenannten
vulderablen Gruppen das sind die die in
aller erster Linie leider auf den
Intensivstationen landen warum sagen
nicht Impfpflicht über 60 das sind 3
Millionen Leute die zu organisieren und
zu kriegen das kriegt man in weniger
Zeit hin jedenfalls als den ganzen Rest
und dann legt man sich mit Menschen über
60 an aber in allen anderen nicht was
auch nicht unwichtig ist in dem
Zusammenhang warum kann man es nicht so
machen pragmatisch müsste jetzt gerade
sein Kontakte reduzieren ganz
pragmatisch um diese vierte Welle zu
brechen das wäre der Lockdown ganz genau
und das und das und man muss eben dahin
gehen vor allen Dingen mit den Maßnahmen
wo die meisten Übertragungen stattfinden
das ist eher in den jüngeren
Altersgruppen der Fall wenn wir
mittelfristig eben eine Lösung haben
wollen dass die
älteren Menschen nicht mehr so schnell
sich infizieren erkranken davon anteilig
und dann auf die Intensivstationen
kommen dann muss man in der Tat sehen
dass man da den Impfschutz
vervollständigt und da kann man nur
immer noch für werben und dann
möglicherweise diskutieren wie das denn
wäre für einen für einen für eine
entsprechende Impfpflicht aber auf jeden
Fall oder auch nicht in dem Moment wo
das Gesundheitssystem nicht mehr
überlastet ist ist es doch die
individuelle Entscheidung eines jeden
Einzelnen ob er sich impfen lässt oder
nicht richtig aber man sollte nicht es
den Leuten überlassen die in dem
Gesundheitswesen arbeiten das ist
nochmal was das Pflegepersonal und das
medizinische Personal die sollten auf
jeden Fall geimpft sein dass ungefähr so
wie wenn ein Operateur in den OP geht
und hat sich nicht die Hände gewaschen
so ungefähr ist das wenn ein ungeimpfter
im Pflegebereich oder sonstwo in der
Medizin tätig ist und also das kann man
ja vielleicht schon mal als erstes in
Angriff nehmen und das was sie gerade
erwähnt haben das nächste also dass man
dann sich ansieht wie man das ganze
sicherer macht das sind auch
Diskussionen die wir führen müssen auch
mit Blick auf die Zeit nach der akuten
Phase dieser Pandemie ist dann
weitergehen wird wie wir dann in einen
sicheren und wieder normalen Zustand zu
bekommen